dunque cos'è successo beh diciamo che è
stato un week end del cazzo
accendo il computer metto una roba
sull'hard disk scendo di sotto faccio
quello che devo fare con l'hard disk
torno di sopra mi muore completamente lo
schermo mi ha abbandonato senza motivo
senza neanche lasciare un bigliettino
come si usa fare quando uno si toglie la
vita niente questo è successo venerdì a
domenica invece mi stavo proprio
preparando per andare a girare quando
detto sai cosa mi sa che è meglio se
metto la telecamera un po in carica il
tempo di prenderla con due mani e
girarmi per andare a scendere le scale
il cordino si aggancia ad uno dei
pomelli del cassetto del comò mela
strappa dalle mani e cade a terra è
infatti anche l'obiettivo mi ha
abbandonato
ora è arrivato l'obiettivo nuovo e
quindi nei prossimi giorni riuscirò a
girare e come hai fatto questo video
cortissimo solo perderci questa ma anche
per dirvi che non sono stato con le mani
in mano in questo periodo poco fa mi
sono imbattuto in un commento lasciato
da un ragazzino che avrà avuto 4 5 6
anni non lo so dalla foto del profilo
sembrerebbe di quelle tali che però non
vi posso far vedere loro dovuto oscurare
di nome giuseppe che ha voluto lasciare
un commento
ti seguo da due anni fa i un blog su
questo commento commento con 3 m
giuseppe io lo so che con il tuo
commento fai un blog su questo commento
tu intendevi dire fai un video su questo
commento è tradotto vorrebbe dire
salutami nel prossimo video e quindi ho
aperto il blog sul commento di giuseppe
chiamato per l'appunto il blog per il
commento di giuseppe commento con 3m che
se volete potete visitare il link in
descrizione quindi perdonatemi ho avuto
un po da fare ho avuto un po di sfiga ma
il leccio arriverà in ritardo ma l'hanno
rivelato sarà per quello che si chiama
leisure